when Jeremy Renner is here he was
talking about how he used his Hawkeye
costume for Halloween have you ever done
that with have you you've never done
that that would totally do that's
allowed Marvel never told me I could do
that I don't I don't I feel like Jeremy
maybe says sorry doesn't ask permission
but he's one of those people you're
actually right I'm one of those people
so yeah because then you can always say
sorry later I would totally do it I'm
not I'm very by the books like I don't I
am the person that is I don't want to be
I'm constantly like I you know I worked
for Marvel for 10 years and I was
constantly terrified I was gonna reveal
some major yeah like anything from like
the color of my that it's like now a
darker shade of Navy it was like you
can't say a thing so I'm I'm sort of
programmed
um to yeah sounds a little abusive but
yeah
programmed I mean yeah I would I don't
do well with Secrets or anything like
that so I would hate that having to keep
a secret I don't know there was
definitely cast members like you know
that are like me yeah that are really
really bad at it
um that are like a liability I call it
passion we're just excited about
something so that's why we give it away
on accident
um but that you said 10 years and this
is like the 10th anniversary of the
first Marvel movie coming out so like
our Avengers movie coming out so what do
you remember like what's one of your
favorite ones like of being a part of it
um I mean because it seems like such a
fun set it's they're all yeah I've had
the most fun on the on the Marvel movies
just because you have a whole family
there that you come back to every you
know year and a half or whatever and so
you know it's been an adjustment not
having
you know my peeps around like that um I
would say you know the first Avengers
was amazing just because it was such a
if you felt it was just like wild west
and not that genre had not been
you know it was it was it was just quite
established yeah it wasn't established
exactly in the same way and so it felt
like we were doing some we didn't know
if it was gonna work and you know it
just kind of felt like a crazy work her
network for all the crazies like me like
I am upset so
film the movie right we do and we
immediately got coffee before we we ever
filmed because you know we did never met
outside of the chemistry but even after
the chemistry read I think it was so
clear the call that we came after the
chemistry from drama was like so it's
cute right I was like right yeah okay
we're on the same
um and we were in Atlanta and then we I
was like let's grab coffee yeah we hung
out for two three four hours walked
around found an art commune yeah we just
stumbled across this art commune and
like this railroad area and it was such
a random moment we were like silent for
like two minutes walking just looking at
everything and the Noah just turns to me
and he's like who let us be superheroes
and then we just started dying and that
was kind of like the start of just this
beautiful like relationship
um and just like friendship you know
with with Noah couldn't be more thankful
for it yeah
[Applause]
I I would love to just acknowledge
something so what quintessa just said
you know when they come in with just
that kind of really cool humility of
like who let us be superheroes yeah
that's a kind of like effervescence that
came on set with with these guys it was
really just so cool to see like to watch
these guys come on set with that kind of
appreciation and gratitude but also that
type of like holy yeah we're doing it
it's amazing oh my God and y'all like I
have a six and eight year old they get
so excited it's a cool thing to play
superhero like all the kids you're
literally like they get so excited
you're like Supernatural to them even
though you're really just human like
they they it's a cool part to play like
for a lot of for a lot of kids out there
too it's awesome you showed the movie at
my house there the other week and my
boys and my stock with my boys and all
their friends just went way up it's like
it's like the first time you've done
something amazing for them truly yeah
they were just so blown away
[Laughter]
I could see the faces just beaming with
joy for me and for the whole movie they
just loved it well wait let's talk about
Dr Fate for a minute because what I
found amazing is the whole time I kept
going how does one see when that's your
costume like your your costume has no if
you don't see you have no eyes is it
really oh it's just like putting a
bucket on your head
I mean it looks gorgeous and I did I
mean
yeah he can't see like luckily you don't
like suffer from claustrophobia or
anything like yeah no but well there's
two helmets there was the kind of ornate
beautiful helmet that I carry and then
there's this large bucket helmet that I
would put on my head very briefly
because I couldn't see anything I put it
on oh my God it's ridiculous there was a
there was a point in the movie where I
transformed and it's this kind of
conduct and I have to
reach down and get this bag so action
put it on and it's
sorry sorry let's do it again I loved it
was like your your doctor fate and like
I guess fate is in someone else's hands
because you can't see
it was amazing
um okay so Contessa um you're one of the
first non-binary actors to play a
superhero in the DC Universe so what
does that mean to you it's got to feel
pretty cool
um I mean I think you know maybe I'm one
of the first you know I'm I'm out so
that's yeah you know that's that's one
thing you know there could be people who
are questioning or you know
um you know still figuring you know what
that means to them and their gender
identity but for me I think it just
it's an incredibly like
I don't like take it lightly I I think
because as a young kid
um I never would have thought that like
someone who's non-binary or trans could
be open
um enough with who they are and like
showcase who they are you know globally
and get you know far and be able to do
the things that they've always dreamed
of and you know just fully just Embrace
who they are so I think being here and
like being out and you know discussing
these things and even you know you
asking that question is so important
because there could be a a young trans
person or someone who's just questioning
who needs to see themselves represented
in some sort of way just to know that
they can do anything that they dreamed
of so absolutely
[Applause]
what did the role of Hawkman mean to you
yours is so cool
[Applause]
and your Chemistry are so hilarious how
y'all are fighting like a lot of them
yeah
no in terms of like what it meant to me
it's uh first of all definitely I am a
superhero fan I got into the game
because of DC I just wanted to do jobs
to go buy toys and Comics you know so
for me to be able to present Hawkman
this titular figure in this way for the
first time on a film with this amazing
cast with the biggest Scott Dawn
Superstar
it doesn't get better than that but
for me on the back end even more
important you know much accused point
being able to be a vessel in the
Progressive conversation that allows
little black and brown kids to see
themselves and see that impossible is
possible they can never go back to
thinking oh I can't be a part of that or
that's imaginary they now the standard
is I'm supposed to be there that's right
and that is
I save this all the time on the show but
inclusivity is important for everyone
not just those who don't feel like
they're represented it's important for
my kids to see every culture to know
every it's important for every kid to
see everything like it's just as
important because
your my kids would be missing out on
that opportunity to learn something
that's important what it does is
cohesively it allows us as a culture to
move forward towards that Progressive
goal together as a unit which is how it
should be yeah I agree I agree speaking
of your kids
when the first black panther came out oh
yeah so what was the family rule they
weren't allowed well
you know they're so impressionable yeah
you know and and you you get a lot of
perks and entree and all of that yeah
Hollywood you know being in the business
that we are yeah and it's not for them
yeah but so it's you want them to have
be normal have a normal childhood and
also work hard for the things you know
yeah work hard period like we did yeah
yeah and uh nothing beats that and so we
wouldn't Courtney took it so far like no
we're going to drive them they're not
driving in limos or cars you know to
places to the airport just bring a
regular old little car you know that
sort of thing but when Black Panther
came and just the representation that it
offered we thought it was very important
on the screen superhero you know the
audiences that were there and um and
also just to um you know get a little
love from kids because a lot maybe your
kids are still in love you know still in
awe of you but he doesn't want to hug
you know she's like Mom yeah sometimes
whatever you can to impress them I'm
holding on to it um but speaking of
black panther do you feel like the
success of a movie with a largely Black
cast has changed Hollywood at all
or do you feel obviously there's a ways
to go I feel like uh always ways ago
always a distance we can cover that's
great we never never get to the end and
this Perfection but there's always this
push and pull and back and forth but
definitely the success of that movie
over a billion dollars you know is makes
a couple of people like uh yeah take a
good look yeah you know and that that
old adage we used to hear about black
movies not traveling you know across the
seas it's you know in markets foreign
markets it's not particularly true yeah
so each you wouldn't know unless you
make them yes success yeah but you um so
you you had to make a wakanda Forever
Without Chadwick so did the cast was it
kind of odd at first did y'all do
anything oh when we when we uh arrived
in you know on the set you know a couple
of days before you know reading through
and and um rehearsals and stuff it was
planned and the producers and
directorate plan had rented a plane and
we all flew to South Carolina and we
went to visit together his his resting
place together and every it was a
beautiful day his his uncles were there
his cousin and we just you know just
spoke from our heart about him helped
felt about him or times with him you
know and that was really really lovely a
great way to just begin because you know
we miss him terribly yeah then when we
got to the set he was like okay we've
had this moment of coming together and
now we've got to come to work and that's
what he would want for us I know it's so
fun it feels like the movie it feels
like that's something you would have
done in wakanda like if someone passed
you know what I'm saying like that feel
it feels I'm such a fan sorry I'm
keeping my cool I'm like really excited
about the new movie everyone is excited
that Shazam is back so was it fun to
kind of get in superhero mode oh
absolutely yeah I mean it's such an
incredible gift of a job like ever since
I was a little kid I dreamed about being
an actor and I get to do that and that
just blows my mind still and I also
always dreamed about being a superhero I
think we all do when we're kids and I
never really let go of that uh so so but
the cool thing is like I love Tom Hanks
in big and I love Christopher Reeves and
Superman and I get to play like the love
child of that boat what a great yeah it
really is a big Superman and it's so fun
and I just get to tap into my inner
child that I never really grew out of on
a daily basis and just bring that to
life and the fact that I got to do that
once was already incredible now I get to
do it again and we get to bring the
whole family the whole shazamly back
together all the rest of the cast I love
the sharing of the I'm not running it
watch the first one spoiler alert but
like you shared the powers I think that
that's such a great lesson yeah it's
like it's such a great message overall
and also in this new one you get to body
slam Helen Mirren oh yeah that's cool
yeah like a game you have to body slam a
date yeah I get the suplex a Dame into
concrete
um it's a big fight it's so it's so dope
this scene that scene right there is so
fun that was the first thing we got to
work together on it was like three pages
of us just having dialogue and I was so
like what am I doing this is Dame Helen
Mirren right now and she's right after
that so everything goes and everything
goes Super South yeah go super South but
she's the coolest she honestly I think
she yeah she she's she's the undameest
Dame she doesn't throw it around she's
just like she's just like a really chill
like human who wants to roll up her
sleeves and jump in the sandbox and have
fun and that's the kind of actor you
want to work with always yeah yeah and
she's an icon on top I already loved her
but now I love her more from that
knowledge and she this fight is
incredible yeah okay so can you tell us
anything about the new Captain America
ironically enough I got my script today
this is the sign like today I literally
I'll show you the email I got my script
today haven't read it haven't opened it
okay I haven't got my passcode to the
website to the website I will read it
for you
we literally get a passcode to a website
that gives us a location to meet the
person to sign to sit with a computer
and read our script wow they don't trust
y'all they don't trust nobody and
there's always like some 21 year old
intern and he just hates you you know
he's sitting there eating Cheetos and
he's like read faster you know and I'm
like I'm just like sick and he's like I
don't care like oh it's a whole thing oh
wait are you dyslexic yeah oh my God
everybody's dyslexic no no no my I know
that's interesting my daughter like
literally was crying the night because
she can't keep up she's dyslexic and
they just kind of figured it out and she
was happy and I was telling her that a
lot of artists actually so many actors
our brains were different and that's
what I told her I was like it's special
though you see it differently it's just
that most of humanity sees it one way
that doesn't make it wrong 100 but it's
so cool I love your freaking Captain
America
yeah
Shazam Fury the God so what was it like
playing a villain goddess
um well first of all I'd seen the first
one and been completely Charmed by it I
loved it so when they said would you
like to be in Shazam I sort of like oh
yeah that you know I loved the first one
so why not and then the word goddess
came up hell yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it's incredible and I didn't know like
you did some of your stunts right
because I did I'm hoping you didn't do
the seam that you just get yeah Shazam
takes you out like a lot I did do that
to you you did I did I mean not all of
them okay but I did a little picture
behind-handed oh yeah yeah but I hand it
to him you do well I was trying not to
spoil her away yeah
she handed him as well
this is the result of my stunt oh my God
are you kidding you can you see how bent
that one see this one's nice and
straight that's my Shazam finger yeah I
feel like
common so I've been I didn't break it
but I bent it
did that to you a concrete wall oh
concrete wall
the fight I was having to hit Zach and
and the stunt guy said you must follow
through because otherwise it doesn't
look good so I went okay I'll follow
through you know bam right into the
concrete wall so
um but I was very stunty you know which
is yeah no it's fine it's fine no it
doesn't it's fine no carry on it's like
killing you and you're like no no no I'm
great I'm great yeah
oh I would have been a baby about it 70
s
about it I love it though I didn't know
uh the whole story behind
um we had Zachary here and I didn't know
the whole story behind even how Shazam
his name like I didn't I didn't realize
like how the gods fit into it and
everything and I thought that was really
cool because I love mythology it was a
great idea yeah because they were the
Superman they were the superheroes of
2000 years ago yeah that was why people
told stories about them yeah they did
superhero e type things they'd come down
they swoop in they'd you know they'd um
save the day save the day but do other
naughty things yeah and um but yeah they
were the superheroes of the days I love
too that the characters that you played
you and your sisters it wasn't all bad
there was reasoning I like whenever you
hear the reasoning like the back story
yes yes it was very they're complex yes
not rooting for them but you're kind of
right yeah it's kind of wrong yeah yeah
they did a really good job and The
Sibling relate The Sibling Rivalry yeah
and we were one of your sisters is a
psycho
that's Lucy Liu yeah but she's not in
real life yeah no no no in real life we
became the just we became sisters
definitely Lucy and I yeah the minute we
walked on set we just bonded and we're
just great great we we are we call each
other sister now that's so cool because
it doesn't always work out that way
usually Kim you know chemistry sometimes
like weird yes yeah great chemistry so
we need to talk
super stoked I'm a Marvel like freak so
where do we
win hope AKA The Wasp where do we find
you in this so because the trailer's so
good oh yeah yeah the trailers are so
good yeah they even like got me yeah
you're like where are they going yeah
they get sucked in yeah yes yeah well in
the first film The Hope was like
permanent wrist resting face right
like that was her just fun to play yeah
really fun to play but now she's like
Perma smile okay she's like she's only
girl scouts yeah she's her relationship
with her dad she's reunited with her mom
she's fallen in love with Scott she's
stepmom and Cassie life is perfect she's
in a really good place okay and she's
spreading all that love to the world
through her humanitarian work and yeah
yeah like things can't go wrong she's
Invincible I like that your character I
know I know I like this tease I'm very
excited but I like the Invincible oh man
how was the costume for you because I
always feel like when y'all wear all
those costumes I hear everybody talk
about how uncomfortable they are what's
yours yeah no I love I mean you love I
took naps in my costume I gotta be
honest dude if I look like that in that
costume I'd probably keep it on too
definitely yeah I would walk into Target
honestly I've said it I've said it
before but I think the reason why people
complain about their costumes is because
the people are mostly male people and
they're not used to suffering for beauty
they're not used to like you know like
horsing it into a gown and you know
we're like welcome to the dark side
it's uncomfortable welcome to leather
and Corset yeah try birth okay so I have
to start with I love the Guardians of
the Galaxy so you know you were the
pursuer so um Cora asked the first story
so is it true that you want to do the
movie for your son
um I would have wanted to do it just to
do it right yeah I mean Guardians do it
just to do it but um it's in reference
to um something that happened with my
son uh that uh from the day he was born
and um some of the films and sort of
animations that he's seen were mostly
Spider-Man
you know uh Batman and so on and over
time and uh and one day he just blurred
out this idea that he uh he wished he
were white in order to climb walls like
Spider-Man and so that really shocked
man and I thought he's never seen a
superhero looking like him yeah see what
I mean and so for him over time the
understanding is we
yeah the looks like yeah don't have the
ability to climb walls like Spider-Man
and so on yeah and so I was eager to
look for some you know content online
that could uh yeah and you know
and come to find out during that time I
uh I had did done a voiceover for Black
Panther and I completed for garbage so
as I was searching and it might and I
that came up and I played it for him and
wait a minute he's like hearing the
voice he's like Baba
you're like yes it is yeah so that's one
of the reasons why I was really drawn to
uh the idea uh you know it is important
for them to see what they can be or
achieve yeah absolutely I love that it's
not just one like Guardians of the
Galaxy is also Shazam
yeah it's like you're in two it's
amazing and Shazam you know luckily
Shazam really is a uh you know it really
speaks of the diversity the idea of yeah
interested in I mean and inclusion even
with the powers yeah this idea of uh you
know uh dealing with magic and being you
know playing an ancient Wizard and uh
the country where I come from Benin
Republic is a place where
um magic and um you know uh this idea of
uh you know the forces of nature we very
much uh very connected to that yeah
which is real yeah and through this idea
of uh you know this way of life that's
called voodoo
and Voodoo over time had suffered
tremendous uh defamation
uh this the notion is that this is a
evil yeah an evil way of you know
practicing uh some sort of like
religious uh well that's something so
big bummer it sure is a big bottom but
it's a it was due to slavery I've come
to find out when I finally decided
because I wanted to
um understand why there was such a bad
name like negative connotation negative
connotations yeah Voodoo and so I wanted
to do a documentary about it because
again I come from a country in which uh
you know now
um every uh January 10th it's a national
celebration throughout the country and
even um people from uh various places in
the diaspora I mean in Cuba Dominican
Republic Brazil they travel all the way
to Benin to celebrate wow so this so the
documentary will kind of explain what it
really is right I try and then and I
think this is you know one of the most
challenging things I ever come to you
know came to uh to trying to realize and
um uh it's they don't really like to
talk about it God I can't wait to see
this documentary what's it called again
in search of Spirit In Search in search
of Spirit In Search of video okay
awesome
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
I'm going
[Music]